تهدف إلى هدف محدد - غضب
المدفعية الأوكرانية
لا شيء في هذه الحرب يمر دون أن يرى ولا حتى
الروس الذين يدخلون هذا المنزل على
بعد ثمانية كيلومترات من
الهدف الذي أنقذته الأساطير الأوكرانية
أثناء محاولتهم تحريك
خط المواجهة إلى الأمام، يجب على هؤلاء المدفعية الآن
انتظار الأفضل  الإحداثيات من
طائرة المراقبة بدون طيار
هي أن
أوديسا يطلب من رجاله خفض البندقية درجة
واحدة
بين الطائرات بدون طيار والمدفعية، ولم يبق أي شيء
للصدفة. ما كانوا
يستهدفونه هو مبنى على
الجانب الآخر يوجد به مشاة روسية
ومدفعية روسية داخل الطائرات بدون طيار.
يرشدونهم وهم على وشك إطلاق النار
للمرة الثالثة وما يقولونه هو أننا
يجب أن نتوقع ردًا من المدفعية الروسية القادمة
هذه المرة، إنها ضربة ليس فقط
المبنى ولكن الذخيرة والمدفعية الروسية
أيضًا مما يعني أن
الانتقام يجب أن يكون سريعًا.  وحان
الوقت للتحرك بأسرع ما يمكن، فالرد
لن يستغرق وقتًا طويلاً في
الخارج
لأنه كما هو متوقع، تبعت
المدفعية القادمة علينا
الآن الابتعاد بأسرع ما
يمكن على الرغم من أن
ما يفسرونه هو أن الأمر ليس مجرد
المدفعية القادمة واحدة من
أخطر الأشياء في القيادة حول
هذه الأجزاء
هي الطائرات بدون طيار
من موقعه في الجزء الخلفي من
الشاحنة الصغيرة. يستطيع أوديسا سماع ورؤية
النيران القادمة
اذهب اذهب اذهب اذهب اذهب،
إنه يطلب منا القيادة بسرعة
بسبب المدفعية القادمة  نجاح باهر
في جميع قذائف المدفعية التسعة تم إطلاق
قدر من الغضب الروسي واليوم
لهؤلاء الجنود الأوكرانيين
نجاح
اندفاع البقاء على قيد الحياة لهذا اليوم على الأقل
الأجنبية